we got this from the post to Millennial
internet explodes with memes after Mike
Pence commits career suicide and
interview with Tucker Carlson following
Pence's I'm sorry social media exploded
on Friday after former vice president
Mike Pence spoke with Tucker Carlson at
The Summit in Iowa claiming that
American cities are quote not my concern
while reiterating his support for the
U.S sending more tanks to Ukraine now I
want to play this clip make sure I
actually play the full clip because when
I first saw it I felt like we weren't
getting the proper context and this
might not actually be the full context
so well let's let's just play this clip
and see if we have it then we'll talk
about it
there's a plan oh come on Twitter we
love Twitter but not when that happens
all right where's the audio at
right there actually
all right and now I am uh there we go I
have enough here we go you are
distressed that the ukrainians don't
have enough American tanks every city in
the United States has become much worse
over the past three years drive around
there's not one city that's gotten
better in the United States and it's
visible our economy has degraded the
suicide rate has jumped public filth and
disorder and crime have exponentially
increased and yet your concern is that
the ukrainians a country most people
can't find on a map who've received tens
of billions of U.S tax dollars don't
have enough tanks I think it's a fair
question to ask like where's the concern
for the United States in that well it's
not my concern
Tucker I've heard that routine from you
before but that's not my concern
I'm running for president of the United
States because I think this country is
in a lot of trouble
I think Joe Biden has weakened America
at home and abroad
and as president of the United States
we're going to restore Law and Order in
our cities we're going to secure our
border we're going to get this economy
moving again and we're going to make
sure that we have men and women on our
Courts at every level that will stand
for the right to life and defend all the
god-given Liberties enshrined in our
constitution anybody that says that we
can't be the leader of the Free World
and solve our problems at home has a
pretty small view of the greatest nation
on Earth we can do both
so before the show we were watching this
the question was is did he literally
just say that American cities are not
his concern and uh Phil you you had do
you want to give your point of view yeah
I mean look I think that he was
answering the previous time that Tucker
said was referring to his concern so
Tucker says you're concerned with
Ukraine and giving money to Crane Etc to
Ukraine et cetera and then Tucker goes
on to say there's uh all these problems
at home and then Tucker uses the phrase
uh concern again
I think that Pence was replying to the
first time that he used uh first time
that Tucker used uh concern because then
Pence goes on to talk about the problems
in the United States you know and so
what's the the finality of his his
statement he does talk about Ukraine but
he says if you think we can't do we
can't be the leader of the Free World
then you got a small view yeah it it
May I'm sorry man like I hear what
you're saying and part of me is like
maybe we give him the benefit benefit of
the doubt but uh I I can't do it I'm not
giving I mean I wouldn't vote for his
ass anyway so it doesn't matter but like
I mean but I just what I mean seriously
so I mean I do think it's funny that
everybody like this is going viral
there's like 50 000 Tweets in the past a
couple hours or whatever and I'm just
like ain't nobody was gonna vote for
this guy in the first place like I mean
he's he's what's he what's he uh
trending at on the on the on predicted
Market uh three cents yeah he's he's
below Nikki Haley this is barely working
it's barely it's only worth talking
about for jokes you know or to you know
to discuss what did people mean you know
there it goes oh my stars and guarders
my friends we just refreshed this to
pull up Mike Pence's numbers Vivek
ramaswamy is nearly tied with Ron
DeSantis Ron dropping down now to 15
cents with the vague skyrocketing the
13-up three with round down one closing
it on second place these are not polls
these are prediction markets there is a
slight correlation obviously with
polling but these are people making bets
on who they think is going to win and
what you're basically seeing is real
time uh I would say
decentralized computing power as to what
may actually happen so these these
prediction markets have a tendency to be
correct but it's not absolute
what do you think
I think uh I I think his statement is
the equivalent of going home telling
your wife that uh hey she didn't mean
anything the cashier who checked me out
you know was pretty professional so it
doesn't really matter what you say after
that statement it did a lot of damage
and it doesn't really acknowledge that I
think he's missing his base right that
uh people here especially people who
would already be more inclined to vote
for him than say someone on the left
don't want us in Ukraine and they don't
want us involved in a bunch of globalist
nonsense so he's missing the mark
anyways by talking about whether the
fact that we can do both people don't
want you focusing on both they want you
focusing here at home right now I don't
care if we send tanks to Ukraine
personally
you don't you mean you don't care if
we're doing it as in you don't care to
do it no no no I don't care to send
weapons of mass destruction over to a
country it sounds like you were saying
let them do it I don't care oh no no no
no yeah yeah thanks for the things
I don't want my tax dollars fighting
another yeah yes yes yes political
suicide well you know I'm a Libertarian
so it's kind of hard to kill me off
that's why I was like what
so ultimately I think the big news
yesterday which we only talked about a
little bit Joe Biden calling in reserves
selected reserves and ready reserves to
be sent to Europe yep I'm sorry man
our our culture today
does not support this kind of foreign
intervention it's just for whatever
reason you know what I think it is I
think Ron Paul has a lot to do with it I
think Ron Paul was speaking up in the
late 2000s to a lot of young people
people my age that and not to mention
combined with the anti-war stuff that
was coming uh during the the bush years
and then all of a sudden we're like you
got Democrats saying no war you got
round Paul run as a republican saying no
war hey you know what most of us agree
with that position and don't see a good
reason for U.S intervention overseas we
look back at history we look at what the
founding fathers thought of this and we
say ultimately yeah we shouldn't be
doing it now that's a big problem for
the neocons and the neolibs and people
like Mike Pence who are like we're
leaders of the Free World yeah what he's
really saying is your labor the work you
do every day when you look at your
paycheck and you see that negative
number for income tax it's going to
bombs and guns and tanks and now they're
deploying more U.S Personnel the
reserves that's that's terrifying to be
sent to Europe for this what is it
Atlantic resolve or whatever it's called
why how about our borders how about our
roads and that's exactly what Tucker was
saying to to Mike Pence I got to tell
you this is not his concern if he right
if he couldn't navigate that question
properly and he had to imagine this it's
like you you nailed him he said mean
that much to me to your wife Mike Pence
is basically saying to the face of all
of these people begging to know why our
money is going overseas don't worry it's
somewhat worth it for some vague and
nebulous reason but I'll take care of
the rest too it's exactly as you
describe telling your wife don't worry
she doesn't mean anything establishment
Republicans are trying to have their
cake and eat it too they really want to
because there are still Hawks in the
Republican party that want to see the
United States be an expansive uh Power
and they want to see the United States
return to a situation similar to
probably prior to the Iraq War they love
the bush years too yeah you know so I
mean to think that to think that he's
not trying to play to both I think is
probably misguided because like he's got
he has to get Trump's voters you know
hypothetically if he's going to win he
has to convince enough Trump voters and
he has to convince people in the middle
people in the middle are not going to be
compelled by a guy that's that's
essentially a religious uh
fundamentalist or borderline at least
he's a very religious person I don't
know if you call him fundamentals but
whatever he's very religious I I yeah I
don't think so I think he's like stock
neocon with can with a religious tent
for the purpose of getting votes well
yeah he was the reason why he was such a
good thing for Trump right because he he
colored him and he was supposed to be
the established but he was also supposed
to be the guy that made it okay for the
the evangelicals to vote for Trump yeah
that was part of the reason why they
picked him too is because of his his
kind of I mean I had a bunch of friends
that are progressives that were like no
really he tried to shock the gay out of
people when when Pence got elected or
when when Trump got elected so like
there was a whole lot of people that
were afraid of it at least afraid of his
his religious Bona footies or whatever
um but I he's got to get the middle and
I don't think that there's any kind of I
don't see a path for him just overall I
don't see how he gets the middle and
satisfies Trump voters and stuff who
want nothing to do with Ukraine and also
satisfies like the faffold morons on on
Twitter you know it's antithetical to
the populist movement that's going on
right now which is very very anti-war
yeah yeah
now a lot of people I I think there's a
lot of people for some reason who like
pants or like come on you know he didn't
really mean that and it's just you know
my response that is like okay fine Fair
Point whatever if that's what you want
to believe
but in the world of politics let's just
talk superficially
Pence just
he just he just stumbled on a black
sandbag on stage and fell down in front
of everybody it doesn't matter if that's
what he wanted you to believe or even
what he meant it's what matters is what
people take from what you said and the
moment you give them a sound bite that
juicy it doesn't matter what you meant
because history won't remember it he
just fell up the stairs three times in a
row
but I mean look look I mean who likes
Mike Pence what does he have to offer us
but but for real can we can we name any
real policy of of pencils I can tell you
this I know one policy of his more money
and weapons for Ukraine never go into a
room with a woman without your wife
there that's the only policy of his I
remember look that's that's some like if
you're if you're trying to like if
you're in DC and trying to navigate DC
it's probably not a bad idea it's a very
good idea the pension rule I don't think
I remember though Mike Pence was
basically Whispering you hey dude it's
me too era yeah make sure your wife is
with you at all times and then they
attack him for it for that reason
probably yeah because you know some of
these weirdos want to lie cheat and
steal and accuse people of all sorts of
nasty stuff they made they made a whole
big deal about about him calling his
wife mother because because it was with
the it's always are you not allowed to
go to dinner you have mother and blah
blah blah you know and then Kavanaugh
happens and they wonder why it was such
a big deal like yeah shocking thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time